still getting yeah still you have to hit
it on the positive side can hit it on
top range right there you go
so you see somebody she left the phone
okay let's rewind behind this technique
better we'll start on your objective so
I'm going to create an angle deflection
and join it with the angle of daeviation
about it and an angle of attack phone so
I need to be able to see what you can
put your hair but I need to have my body
of law here so that this hand can drop
under my Center things start going wrong
when i do this it's not going to drop my
device and drop me outside my face
you'll see that you'll do that a lot you
move it over here you go too far the
light it so that the center can be
filled by the hand you don't have your
heel to arch alignment or worse you turn
them and you over like that if you step
too far out right in your back here what
happened you met
so there's not just the width of my
stance but the distance of my stance and
the depth of my stance so foot here foot
here are not not reaching goes one and
then I'm going to move this then I can
put my weight on the further i am on the
joke the less or let's say the harder
it's going to be to make that end heavy
the preceding angle deflections has you
right not at the end of the jump so
that's going to tell you how far can I
take this hand that end and hits him
home with it hey try just that way
this is not a vlog and this is not your
yen mood this is a weakening of your
wrist right now okay so you want to keep
this angle in case you get hit that's
what that is in case you get here if
you're moving off the line so as you're
training you're going to continue to use
the jawline to teach you the body
organization so don't move there Joan
it's now not a joke once it's here once
it makes contact it's not a joke it's as
if he does not he's not there but I
still follow that line so he's helping
me train don't move their weapon no here
hey go so I help kids Joe line as my
motivation line then I use the map so
all the toys she should end parallel to
the ground no that's too little no too
much
ok so the training mine is to use this
joke okay so if we're in the technique
the technique line is I don't block
anything that's just my coverage I go
right for his hands oh my for his hands
if you would hit to his attack right so
where do you tap
what are you tap ok where's your tech
here I
whoa vapor lock us week old oh don't
block do you understand okay try that
what is that then that's just a check
that's all you're doing oh it again you
just check in his hands because what's
your next what's your ultimate goal this
ski right boom so watch what I do with
the end of the Joe I bring it right to
the other hand goes right to the hand
you can't just put it anywhere I have to
put in where the scheme and is so I
can't go like that it's not where it is
I can't go like that that's not worth it
it goes right to the other hand so we go
back to the training bold and I want to
concentrate i'm putting that end in this
hand at to put origin for ski no let's
see Kimmy boom
my feet end up in the ski position so
again if you're out here you're not
going to get my scheme have your feet
under your hips so it goes right to the
ski please
which will freighter pain Oh everything
hit five my leg goes in weight shifts
under the back foot power goes into the
bach pad ooh and I come in you can leave
this key off you're just working on that
transition okay let's go